you know it's amazing to me that in this
day and age you could be so
obtuse about sexual orientation i watch
the l word okay
i watch queer as that's what it's called
dick the halls with
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
this is [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
so long
guess what
i just drove my car into a lake you did
what
i drove my car
into a
lake
and now from my old hometown scranton
pennsylvania my former boss michael
scott
hey i just think you should know that
one of my salesmen beat your stupid
computer
so take that ass
okay but look if you want to have kids
then fine you win
do you mean you wanna have a kid
i hate my life
oh my god okay it's happening everybody
stay calm what's the procedure everyone
what's the procedure
oh yeah you asked
toby you gonna eat all that dog food
yourself
you did not have sex with pam's mom oh
big time what kind of cars to drive she
drives a green camera and the seats go
all the way down
all the way down oh my god
oh my god michael let me make this very
easy for you i could give it about your
happiness stop dating my mother
the hell was that i had to do that
[Music]
all right are we good
i i will now show you how to put this
condom on using
this pencil
what
why would you choose a pencil andy well
i'm not gonna use my penis oscar it's
not exactly hard right now anyway come
on give it a rest pencil i'm doing this
for you meredith everyone may have your
attention
i would like to introduce you to mr
danny cordray he is going to be joining
us as our new traveling salesman say
hello to danny
me okay you know what don't let it
happen again you think that i would let
this happen again
no way jose
um
what if we all get together and help
each other and hire a new guy and then
we all kill him but first we take out
like a hundred thousand dollar life
insurance policy i bet you guys like
that idea don't you
i think that's what they're doing to me
i can't prove it but i wanted to see
their faces when i said it
i learned nothing
i don't know what that was uh i get it
everybody knows about the ultimatum yes
i told everyone
hey
right back at you [ __ ]
heard those machines all like 10 bucks
at once actually it's 10 000. holy sh
what what's it
it's so light
like a croissant
one
two three
i did it i did a cartwheel
you oh god okay
that's it i do characters as well i've
got a i got a chinese fella not
politically correct but he's called holy
that's what it sounds like and i was
supposed to tell you to enjoy a mid-hunt
break and um look for a heart or
something in the break room when you're
through
my mom makes the best pesto in the world
and i always tell her mom you should
sell this you'd make a fortune and she
always says no it's just for family well
finally i was like okay i'll sell it i
already have the ring don't think you
need the corpse then there's a ring
holy is that real yeah they say three
years salary
yeah okay
well this is going to hurt like a mother
give me that damn dog
thief
turn up
okay don't ever do it again
what the [ __ ] is that
we just have a lot of serious candidates
to get through today
so
am i not a serious candidate
what do you want me to say i mean
there's a line of qualified people out
there we have a video cv from england
are we all just going to pretend to
okay um
what are your weaknesses i don't have
any ass
all that for this job yes
that's [ __ ] crazy d-dog you have a
message aaron you don't need to call him
that
andy wants us to p-dog
it's okay e-dog just hook up justine she
said she's coming by later
your ex-wife wait i thought she was a
and you hated her guts
there you go whoa no wait wait whoa
oh
sorry
i'm not rebel stiltskin jim i can't keep
spinning gold out of here
okay listen up everyone here's who's
going to florida
kathy what stanley no ryan no aaron
and
jim you got to be
kidding me okay hey daryl good news your
facts went through oh yeah
up high yes sir i'm daryl now daryl i
heard about you you doing good oh yeah
you must be doing real good since you're
my girlfriend
dude you didn't tell me you were [ __ ]
val high five i mean i think it seems
like you're a little nervous yeah no
sherlock hey can we turn this back
around quickly please can we turn this
around quickly this is very important
turn around
turn around
thing around please you're blackmailing
me
it's just business
well
i will not be blackmailed by some
ineffectual privileged effete soft penis
debutant you want to start a street
fight with me bring it on but you're
going to be surprised by how ugly it
gets you don't even know my real name
i'm the lizard king
i just want
one
mother
delicious moment
is that too much to ask
i wish my dad could see me now
of course he caused this whole mess so
him
damn it screw you dad
yeah
i'm gonna tell jim to go himself
i am going through a 12-step program
i'm currently on step zero
which is have a load of fun
dwight you do not learn do you
for a threat to be credible you ha
holy
that's that's awful angela i'm so sorry
it's the that lives downstairs
she's this uptight judgmental shrew you
know the type
i've never met anyone like that eleanor
roosevelt once said
the future belongs to those who believe
in the beauty of their dreams
i think she's right
i feel calm now
get out
i feel like for the first time in a long
time
i'm doing the right thing what the [ __ ]
is your problem
who drives like that i love you
mose
what
oh
moe's
you